representatives from 40 states and
organizations attended the berlin
conference it was organized by germany
to mobilize support for the millions of
syrians who have been affected by the
civil war in their country
after talks the german foreign minister
promised more help to syria's neighbors
who say they can no longer cope with the
huge influx of refugees
but it's a broadening of our position
because we'll be channeling more support
towards the countries and communities
next to syria
who are taking in refugees
the un estimates that syria's civil war
has displaced about 6 million people
within the country
an estimated 3 million have fled to
neighboring countries about 1.1 million
are now in turkey hundreds of thousands
more are in iraq jordan and egypt but
the situation is especially serious in
lebanon which has also taken in more
than a million people
that's a number equivalent to a quarter
of its population
lebanese prime minister tamam salam
appealed to the conference for help
lebanon
as it has been recognized by all
is beyond its absorption capacity
and urgently needs other countries to
share its burden
winter is approaching making the
situation even more dire for the
refugees living in the camps beyond
syria's borders